Je me suis fait attaquer en plein jour.
Crac.
Alors voilà,
il me manque 300 brebis,
ma chèvre.
Je sais pas
ce qu'on va récupérer,
j'en sais rien,
j'en ai plein le cul.
La moindre faille
de l'éleveur ou du berger
va être potentiellement
exploitée par le loup.
Ils savent qu'ils sont surveillés
tout le temps.
Ils savent pas par où
et ils savent que ça va frapper quoi.
Je surveille toute la nuit
à l'aide de la caméra thermique.
C'est un animal
qui est très difficile à trouver.
Il est nulle part
parce qu'on le voit pas.
Mais en fait, il est partout.
Parce que dès qu'on compte,
il en manque.
Salut à tous, c'est Cyrus North.
Je suis avec Tanguy
de la chaîne Toopet.
-  Salut tout le monde.
- Et on est en Haute-Savoie,
dans les Alpes.
On est là pour vous parler
du métier de berger.
- On est venus passer du temps
avec des bergers,
leur poser des questions
sur leur quotidien,
mais aussi sur une problématique
qui les concerne fortement.
- Celle d'un prédateur, le loup.
- Attends, là, c'est ton bureau en fait ?
- Ouais, c'est le bureau.
Tu vois, c'est beau. On a les glaciers.
- C'est pas beau,
c'est incroyable comme bureau.
Franchement, t'as le bureau
le plus classe au monde.
- La cabane,
elle est un peu plus haut,
on la voit pas
mais quand t'es dans la cabane,
tu vois le Mont-Blanc
tous les matins quand tu te lèves.
C'est un alpage où
je gardais moi, il y a trois ans
et c'est des brebis
qui arrivent du sud de la France.
On y va ?
- Yes, c'est parti.
Allez mon gars.
- Allez viens.
Le métier de berger,
c'est vraiment un triptyque relationnel
entre le troupeau,
le berger et les chiens.
Et ce petit monde là
se connaît et travaille ensemble.
- Comment il s'appelle le tien ?
- Nahiko.
- Il est magnifique.
Quel âge il a ?
Il a un an et demi,
c'est un pastor vasco,
un berger basque.
- Y a pas que des chiens de berger
avec les bergers.
Il y a aussi
des “chiens de protection”,
raconte-moi un un peu les patous.
- Donc on a des chiens
qui sont avec le troupeau à l'année
et qui sont là pour écarter
tout danger du troupeau
et qui alertent aussi le berger
quand il y a un souci.
Ça limite un peu les attaques,
on perd beaucoup de chiens
tous les ans qui se font tuer par les loups.
- Elles ont quand même
une belle team de sécurité ces brebis.
Entre toi,
ton chien de berger, ton patou.
- Et pourtant, ça suffit pas.
- Il y a 12 500 brebis
qui sont mortes l'an passé
sous les crocs du loup.
- 12 500,
juste en France ?
- Juste en France.
- Ah, c'est beaucoup.
- C'est beaucoup,
on a que 500 loups en France.
Donc ça fait un bon ratio.
Historiquement,
le loup était présent
sur environ 90 %
du territoire de la France
au 18ème et 19ème siècle.
Mais à l'époque, l'imaginaire français
associe le loup à
un animal dangereux pour l'homme.
La légende de la Bête du Gévaudan,
qui raconte
qu'un loup aurait tué
une centaine d'hommes entre 1764 et 1767,
entraîne une sorte de psychose nationale
pendant plusieurs décennies.
Traqué et chassé dans tout le pays,
il disparaît complètement
au début du 20ème siècle,
vers les années 1930.
Les loups sont réapparus
en France en 1992,
dans le parc du Mercantour.
Le retour des loups en France,
on en a vu
dans l'arrière pays niçois.
Depuis six mois, on relève
en permanence des indices de présence:
traces d'urine, excréments,
touffes de poils et carcasses.
Le loup ne présente aucun danger,
ni pour les troupeaux
ni pour l'homme.
En France en 2018,
l'Office national de la chasse
et de la faune sauvage
a recensé des loups
dans 40 départements.
Il y aurait aujourd'hui
au moins 72 meutes,
toutes situées
dans les Alpes et la Provence.
C'est donc forcément aussi
dans ces régions
que les éleveurs subissent
la majorité des pertes.
En France,
il y a une problématique du loup
parce que ce prédateur carnivore
peut s'attaquer
à des animaux domestiques
notamment des ovins,
comme les brebis, les agneaux, les moutons
mais aussi des chèvres,
parfois des veaux
et plus rarement, des poulains.
Et ça impacte le travail
des éleveurs
et surtout, des bergers qui sont en charge
de la protection de ces troupeaux.
Allez Cyrus !
- T'as pas de chance,
c'est pas encore la saison des myrtilles.
T'aurais pu en avoir là.
- On va déjà faire
la saison des mollets là.
Berger,
c'est un peu sportif quand même.
C'est pas juste,
t'es là avec un bâton, tu fais :
"Hop, hop, hop, là.
Oh les moutons !”
- Je sais même pas comment
il fait pour marcher alors que c'est comme ça.
Nous on grimpe, lui il marche.
Je sais pas comment il fait.
Allez, viens.
T'as le chien qui prévient là,
qu'il nous a vus,
qu'on est dans son territoire,
qu'on est au niveau des brebis.
Donc, on va avancer
tout doucement et on va lui parler.
Ça va Nox. C'est bon.
- Là, le chien, il a bien fait son job,
t'as vu Cyrus?
- Tu me reconnais ?
Hein ?
T'es un bon chien.
Ça va, c'est bon.
Tu veux jouer loulou.
Hey, chut, pas bouger.
Ça va.
C'est bon, on peut y aller.
Comment ça se passe Joseph
quand un loup, il attaque ?
Genre, il arrive là, en pleine journée,
il prend une brebis et il part,
comment ça se passe ?
Tu le vois attaquer?
- Il y a plusieurs configurations.
Là, on est dans un milieu ouvert
donc on peut le voir arriver.
Souvent, ils se cachent et ils ont un pelage,
ça se confond un peu avec la roche.
Ce qui nous fait remarquer
qu'il y a le loup qui est présent,
souvent, c'est que
le troupeau va s'affoler d'un coup,
va partir dans tous les sens.
Là où le troupeau,
il est tous ensemble.
- Ouais, il y a une cohésion.
- Il y a une cohésion.
Et si le troupeau se fait attaquer,
on va avoir soit un lot qui part à droite
soit un lot qui part à gauche.
Les loups sont malins.
Quand ils sont en meute,
souvent ce qu'ils font,
c'est qu'ils attirent les chiens d'un côté.
Pour laisser les deux autres
attaquer de l'autre.
Ça laisse un trou ouvert.
Et ils font quoi ?
Ils les consomment sur place
ou ils vont les traîner
et les emmener ailleurs?
Pareil, il n'y a pas de règle.
Soit c'est consommé sur place,
soit c'est juste égorgé.
Parce qu'il faut...
pour la traîner la brebis
là, quand même,
ça pèse quoi ces animaux,
50, 60 kilos, ça pèse quoi?
Ça peut peser de 45 à 75 kilos
mais on a déjà vu des loups
traîner leurs proies sur 7 km.
7 km ?
Et on voit que c'est du loup
parce que les os sont brisés
ce qu'un chien peut pas faire.
C'est une super espèce
parce qu'il y a à manger dans...
Il y a des chevreuils, des chamois, etc.
Sauf que pour lui, c'est bien plus facile
d'aller attaquer nos troupeaux.
C'est l'opportunisme en fait.
Il va aller calculer la dépense d'énergie
par rapport à son gain.
Elles vont passer là.
Et des fois,
tu fais passer le col
et le loup,
lui, il attend de l'autre côté.
Ça fait cinq ans que je suis louvetier.
On a le droit de le faire
jusqu'à l'âge de 75 ans
donc il y a encore de la marge.
On n'est pas du tout rémunérés,
on est bénévoles,
on a un métier à côté.
Et on intervient
uniquement sur arrêté du préfet.
Ça peut être du renard
sur des poulaillers,
ça peut être du sanglier
dans les champs de maïs,
ça peut être du loup
sur les troupeaux.
On les suit,
on va dire entre parenthèses,
toute l'année par l'intermédiaire
des pièges photo
et, nous ici,
chez nous, de la neige.
Là, on va aller voir
un piège photo
qui a été installé
depuis le début d'hiver.
C'est des pièges photo
qui sont sécurisés
par un boîtier en fer et un câble
pour éviter qu'on nous les vole
parce que c'est très prisé.
Ah voilà.
Je sais pas s'il a été fait
exprès celui-là.
Première photo, il y a un loup
qui arrive dans le champ du piège photo.
Le loup est un animal
particulièrement fantomatique.
Il fait partie des animaux
qui ont une culture
et les loups en Europe
sont persécutés depuis des millénaires
donc ils ont parfaitement
intégré cela
et donc ils savent
se faire extrêmement discrets.
Même pour les naturalistes
qui espèrent le voir,
c'est un véritable Graal.
Au niveau du matériel
qu'on utilise la nuit
pour la surveillance de troupeaux.
Donc, une chose déjà indispensable,
ça s'appelle une caméra thermique,
ça détecte la chaleur
et ça nous permet
de repérer des animaux loin
et pouvoir tirer en sécurité.
L'autre matériel
qu'on a, c'est une arme,
c'est une carabine
qui permet de tirer aussi bien
du sanglier que du cerf
et qui est très efficace
pour tuer parce que le but,
c'est de le tuer
et qu'il parte pas blessé dans la nature.
Sur du loup, je m'en suis servi deux fois,
on va dire efficacement
puisque le loup a été prélevé
et une fois, le loup a été manqué.
Donc du coup,
il est toujours en train de promener.
En 1989, la France
a ratifié la Convention de Berne
qui interdit de chasser
le loup sans autorisation.
L'article 1 stipule notamment
que la convention est là pour
assurer la conservation
de la flore et de la faune sauvage
et de leurs habitats naturels.
Pour réguler la population de loups,
des tirs de prélèvements,
c'est-à-dire la possibilité
de tuer l'animal,
sont autorisés chaque année
entre septembre et décembre.
En 2019, le gouvernement
a donné son feu vert
pour que 17 % des loups soient
abattus contre 10 % auparavant,
les années précédentes.
Si on chasse en dehors de ces quotas,
on fait ce qu'on appelle
du braconnage
donc ça peut coûter très cher.
Notamment des amendes,
des retraits de permis.
C'est déjà arrivé que si
des gens se font attraper
avec du très gros braconnage,
ils font même de la prison.
En fait, on le déteste pas
mais c'est juste que…
à la fin de la saison,
t'en peux plus quoi. T'es crevé.
- Il te harcèle en fait.
J'ai l'impression que c'est du harcèlement de fond.
- C'est comme s'il y avait quelqu'un
qui était sur ton estive avec un fusil,
avec une lunette,
tu le voyais jamais
et tu sais qu'il pouvait tirer
au moindre moment et te blesser.
Là, il blesse tes brebis,
ton troupeau, il te blesse toi
parce que moi, l'an passé,
à cause de la fatigue,
je suis tombé.
Je me suis cassé le coude.
Je cherchais mes bêtes partout.
J'avais les larmes aux yeux
parce que j'ai perdu mes chèvres,
je savais pas où elles étaient.
Et puis, j'en pouvais plus.
C'est juste que t'as beau avoir
de l'aide des éleveurs et tout ça,
à un moment,
t'as les nerfs qui craquent,
t'es pas un surhomme.
Tu peux pas toute la journée
surveiller tes bêtes
et puis tu vois, notre boulot,
c'est de faire manger nos bêtes
et entretenir des espaces
et on t'empêche de le faire.
Et en plus, on te dit que
t'es un mauvais berger
parce que
t'as qu'à garder tes brebis.
Mais moi aux brebis,
j'y suis 15 heures par jour.
Y a personne, qu'il neige,
qu'il vente, sous la pluie, j'y suis.
Moi, j'ai la chance d'avoir
ma femme avec moi.
J'ai une chance fabuleuse de l'avoir
parce que quand t'es tout seul,
je peux dire que tu pètes les plombs.
Faut avoir les nerfs
bien accrochés et être passionné
parce que sinon, tu tiens pas.
Ça le tendait, ça le stressait
et du coup, c'était...
C'était au quotidien,
il fallait prendre sur soi
pour que notre vie de couple
n'en pâtisse pas.
Du coup, il transmet son stress aussi.
- Ouais, tu as quelques jours
où tu angoisses.
- Est-ce si vous aviez le droit
de vous défendre face aux loups,
ça changerait quelque chose ?
- Non.
L'an passé,
j'avais une carabine dans le sac.
La seule chose que ça a changé,
c'est ma dépense énergétique.
Ça pèse, ça pèse lourd
et on l'a vu une fois en pleine journée
et t'as pas le temps de dégainer.
Ça dure cinq secondes.
C'est hyper rapide.
Et puis tes enfants...
Avoir une carabine chargée
dans la cabane.
Tu dors pas pareil avec les gosses.
Donc, je pense, c'est pas la solution...
Enfin pour nous en tout cas,
on n'est pas bergers pour ça.
- Ah ouais ok !
- Ah ouais.
Donc en fait,
c'est une discipline à part entière.
Regardez, démonstration,
c'est parti.
Attention,
qu'est-ce qu'il faut pas faire !
Allez, c'est parti !
On fait moins les malins là.
Allez.
Laisse-toi glisser,
je pense, mets tes pieds face à la...
*Rires*
Voilà, comme ça, c'est bien !
C'est quoi pour toi
la solution aujourd'hui ?
Genre, imagine demain,
tu es président,
tu ferais quoi concrètement ?
- C'est un gros bordel.
Il y a pas de suivi éthologique.
Tout le monde parle du loup,
personne sait comment il se comporte.
C'est-à-dire que tous ceux
qui t'expliquent que ça attaque la nuit,
que c'est pas possible
que ça s'approche de l'homme, etc.
C'est des gens qui connaissent rien,
ils ont juste vu le loup dans les livres.
On en parlait au 18ème siècle
et c'est tout, où les gamins qui allaient garder,
ils faisaient claquer
les sabots et puis le loup fuyait.
Aujourd'hui,
c'est plus du tout comme ça.
On a des environnementalistes
qui veulent absolument pas
qu'on puce les loups
ou les meutes pour savoir
où elles sont.
Parce qu'elles pensent que,
grâce au puçage,
on va aller les tuer.
Il y a une espèce
de paranoïa schizophrène
où tout le monde
se méfie de tout le monde
et du coup, il se passe plus rien
et tout le monde...
personne est content.
Il y a eu une période où on a cohabité
avec le loup, le berger et le loup ?
La cohabitation, elle peut pas exister.
Y a pas de cohabitation possible.
Il y a une coexistence possible
mais pour qu'il y ait coexistence,
il faut qu'il y ait réciprocité.
On est deux prédateurs
en haut de la chaîne alimentaire
et dans n'importe quel milieu,
quand il y a deux prédateurs
sur un même territoire,
l'un et l'autre savent
que s’ils vont sur le territoire de l'autre,
il y a un risque létal.
- Ouais, tu as une concurrence.
- Aujourd'hui, il n'y en a pas.
Aujourd'hui, le loup,
il est surprotégé
et puis, on a
des phénomènes d'hybridation
qui sont compliqués
avec les chiens aussi,
qui créent des comportements
complètement anormaux.
Nous, ce qu'on voudrait,
ce n'est pas qu'il y ait plus de loups,
c'est qu'il y ait zéro brebis tuée.
Par rapport à la montagne
et au pastoralisme en montagne,
ce sera difficile d'avoir le zéro dégât.
L'idéal, ce vers quoi il faudrait tendre,
c'est essayer d'intégrer la contrainte du loup,
la réduire à son maximum,
mais en sachant bien
qu'on ne pourra pas totalement
la faire disparaître.
Ça devrait passer
à 17 % de prélèvements.
On sait très bien
qu'il y a 20% de reproduction,
donc ça veut dire qu'on
n'est toujours pas en phase de stabilisation.
On est toujours
en phase d'augmentation.
C'est plutôt une gestion
par la vengeance,
de l'œil pour œil,
dent pour dent,
comme pour faire
baisser une pression sociale.
Or, est-ce qu'on veut uniquement
faire baisser la pression sociale
ou faire baisser la prédation ?
Ça, c'est vraiment la question
et c'est ce sur quoi il faut travailler.